bonjour à tous j'aimerais partager avec
vous une réflexion qui se veut une
philosophie qui s'appelle le réal et son
double certains pètent société au delà
des conséquences de leurs conséquences
échappe à la banalité notre expérience
ou de notre existence
simplement parce que nous pouvons
identifier avec précision ce que nous
étions en train de faire au moment ils
se sont produits
tel est le cas des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 se souvient tous de ce
que sont en train de faire en tout cas
sur un montage ou plus récemment ceux de
paris ou de bruxelles
au delà des actes de barbarie et d'être
nombreuses victimes que nous devons
déplorer
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans la gestion
des conséquences sociétales de ces
événements qui font du radicalisme le
nouveau paradigme social alors vous me
regardez tous ne me demandez pas de quoi
il s'agit je n'en sais rien je suis
incapable de vous donner une définition
de la radicalisation
tout comme je suis incapable de vous
donner un contenu au concept de
déradicalisation ça ne veut rien dire
comme beaucoup je suis tombé dedans sans
l'avoir demandé et répondre à cette
question à ces questions impliquerait de
motos cre de motos proclamé experts
expert en fabrique d'angoise public et
d'une rhétorique de la peur s'autorise
on ne plus envisager le lien social et
les rapports humains que sous l'angle de
la polarisation il y a eu il y à nous et
l'enfer ma foi c'est les autres comme
disait sartre les faits et leur
médiatisation à outrance ont façonné de
toutes pièces une problématique sociale
qui fait des jeunes radicaliser concept
ô combien flou et vides de contenu mais
à haute valeur médiatique ajouté la
nouvelle classe dangereuse postmoderne
cependant cette jeunesse cependant la
jeunesse n'est qu'un mot et cette
réalité que je côtoie quotidiennement
rend ces catégories mentales et
idéologique inopérante voire stérile
est impossible il tint possible sous
peine de tomber dans une forme de
populisme de bas étage de populisme de
comptoir de subsumer sous un même
vocabulaire ou sous un même vocable des
réalités fort l'hiver c'est qu'ils
traduisent l'existence de sous-culture
le code normatif spécifique de règles de
conduite de pratiques symboliques
soit autant de monde de sens d'univers
de signification qui renvoie notre
société a son propre miroir déformant
dans les politiques publiques qu'elles
touchent le champ scolaire ou éducatifs
n'assure plus aujourd'hui que le service
après-vente des rapports sociaux et les
jeunes ne sont pas dupes
à quoi bon participer ici et maintenant
une société de nous avons perdu le mode
d'emploi et dont le stock de pièces de
rechange a été totalement épuisé il n'y
a que chez un grand constructeur de
meubles suédois que vous voyez à l'écran
que les modes d'emploi sont déchiffrable
avec les outils fournis avec deux
laissés pour compte en boucs émissaires
certains jeunes se socialise à travers
un monde d'illusions sorte le nouveau
monde virtuel qui tend à devenir la
seule réalité vécue car pour beaucoup
que reste-t-il du monde une fois qu'ils
aient été expurgés de ses illusions
rien si ce n'est la réalité subi cette
réalité crue et cynique qui fait du
mépris social et d'indifférence
généraliser la question essentielle donc
pas de savoir comment empêcher des
jeunes de se radicaliser de partir vers
la syrie et l'irak des zones de combat
ou d'opter pour le terrorisme la
criminalité la question et rita
véritablement de savoir comment les
faire consentir au réel à notre réelle
tout se passe comme s'il existait le
réel et son double comme l'a si bien
expliqué le philosophe clément rosset
philosophe français qui
je m'inspire pour cette intervention il
n'y a rien de plus fragile que la
faculté humaine d'admettre la réalité il
ya rien de plus fragile que la faculté
humaine d'admettre la réalité il s'agit
là d'une des pratiques les plus
communément admise chez nos semblables
y compris chez nos édiles politiques 1
qui plus que d'autres cultivent cette
faculté d'oblitérer le réel d'un simple
clignement des yeux ignorer ce que l'on
voit nier ce que l'on sait
n'acceptez le réel car certaines
conditions ou jusqu'à un certain point
tel constituent les modalités du refus
de ce réel car le real est ainsi fait
d'illusions qui s'interpose entre nous
et le monde et qui traduisent le hiatus
entre le monde tel qu'on le vit et des
espoirs que nous y avons légitimement
placé alors ya ptet des étudiants en
philosophie dans la salle mais avouez
quand même un côté platonicien tout ceci
rappelez-vous le grand philosophe grec
nous enseignent dans le mythe de la
caverne que l'humanité enfermé dans une
caverne n'a accès qu'à une réalité qui
ne constitue que le reflet ou la pâle
copie de la réalité extérieure est
immuable ce qu'il appelle le monde des
idées et dont seul le philosophe
éclairée par la quête du savoir peut
prendre connaissance pour en sortir
cette caverne à trouver aujourd'hui sa
production moderne à travers le lit d où
l'image du ghetto mentale sorte de
prison de verre fait de stigmates
intériorisé de discriminations
ressenties et dont les parois de la
caverne ont laissé place à des vitres
transparentes rien plancher gluant
duquel certains jeunes se sentent
incapables de décoller alors pour un
esprit rationnel quelques vous et moi
north à dire normalement constitué ceux
qui existent existe ce qui n'existe pas
n'existe pas pas besoin de polémiquer
pas besoin de tergiverser
pourquoi alors adhéré à la dette à
l'existence d'un monde virtuel et ainsi
transcender les frontières invisibles
notre réalité
pour adhérer à son double cette question
nécessite évidemment de métro
d'emprunter des nez d'un enfant qui
découvre le mot
avec innocence il n'ya pas pire
injustice que celle à laquelle on ne
peut pas donner de sens pour un jeune
leur à défaut de pouvoir la comprend de
lui donner sens et de la rendre
intelligible
on l'a inscrit dans un univers de sens
qui permet d'appréhender le monde sous
un jour nouveau
je côtoie tous les jours cette quête
d'intelligibilité du réel à travers un
sentiment d'appartenance très fort à la
marque 10,80 code postal de molenbeek à
bruxelles qui est un véritable label
identitaire pour les jeunes cette quête
identitaire et cette quête
d'intelligibilité rejaillit également au
niveau de la sémantique verbal vous les
belges nique la police nick les keufs
aujourd'hui je me suis encore fait à
gare par ces de keufs
c'est à dire aujourd'hui je suis pour
faire arrêter et violenté par la police
ou encore on va tout faire péter
ou encore on va finir le travail de
paris ici qu'il me soit permis d'amender
présenter mes excuses pour ses propos si
peu châtié ce langage peu châtié ou ses
propos choquants soto riner de si grande
audience
mais après tout ne faut-il pas osé
nommer un chat un chat
je vous promet cependant que les
douceurs arriveront avec les deux
intervenantes qui vont me suivre dans ce
contexte donc il me faut être ou devenir
guérisseur de l'âme dix mois les
injustices que tu as subi dix mois de
quoi tu t'estimes victimes
je te dirai à quel double du réel tu
adhères l'alcool la drogue
l'esprit clanique la fatalité du
quartier la rupture avec la société ne
confirme in fine et qu'une seule chose
certains jeunes cherchent à tout prix à
fuir leur destin certains jeunes sont de
plus en plus déconnectés du réel de la
société de leur famille de leur réseau
sans doute pour échapper à l'asphyxié du
présent un comble pour une société qui
est celle de l' hyper connectivité fuir
leur destin l'histoire de ces jeunes est
pour ainsi dire aussi ancienne que celle
de l'humanité
rappelons nous des deep and oracle avait
prédit qu'il durait son père et qu'il
épouserait sa mère
pour éviter cette prédiction il est
séparé de ses parents et a pris
connaissance de l'oracle et dit quitte
ses parents adoptifs et fuite loin très
loin mais dans sa fuite va rencontrer
son père le tuer
résoudre l'énigme du sphinx épouse et sa
mère on a tous entendu tous appris cette
histoire à l'école ça c'est fait quoi et
deep en fouillant ne fait qu'accomplir
son destin il ne fait que parachever
ainsi la prédiction 2500 ans plus tard
semi très une actualité vive oracle
moderne
certains jeunes vont intégrer dès le
plus jeune âge le sentiment d'être né du
mauvais côté de la barrière
tout porte à croire que l'objectif de
l'existence consiste à échapper un
oracle qui leur président et qui leur
prédisaient cette impossibilité de faire
partie intégrante de la société
comme citoyen comme sujet à part entière
comme il dit qui s'écrivait les yeux
pour ne pas voir la réalité ces jeunes
cachés réels qu'ils ne seraient voir
pour conjurer leur destin le paradoxe
est qu'il n'arrive par l'acca le porter
jusqu'à son terme
l'une des modalités suprême de ceux de
cette négation du réel se nomme
aujourd'hui complotisme ou théorie du
complot a l'air de l'humain 2.0 qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui dans cet amphithéâtre
à l'ère de la pause vérité ou de la
tyrannie du fai alternatifs il est admis
universellement aujourd'hui à travers le
système technicien qui nous entoure
c'est à dire le système qui technicien
qui est le nôtre que tout le monde peut
émettre un avis sur tout
la profusion des sources d'accès au
savoir leur prétendue égalité
rampeau reuze les frontières du
rationnel et légitime ce que d'aucuns
ont appelé le révisionnisme instantanée
des faits objectifs
tout est dans tout et le complot est
partout retenez bien ça le révisionnisme
instantanée des faits objectifs
le complot est ainsi dire
consubstantielle à la vérité mis sur un
pied d'égalité en somme le complot
permet ainsi aux jeunes de s'éloigner de
ceux qui irrémédiablement les rendent
monde subit pour se tourner vers un
manque qui aurait été épurée de son
absurdité et de toute sa dramaturgie
raconte moi ce que tu vis je te dirai à
quel complot tu dois croire et quel
complot légitimer la société à cette
prétention de voir les choses d'en haut
d'un ton particulièrement hautain et
méprisant et qui diagnostique dans le
radicalisme l'action d'un individu isolé
ou de réseaux clandestins
c'est vrai telle est la réalité aussi
transparente et indubitable ci est
indubitable que la terre est ronde et
qu'elle tourne autour du soleil
mais ne serait ce pas là cependant une
autre modalité du déni du réel
nier certaines évidences pour éludé des
questions pourtant essentielles ou pour
légitimer une injection d'acide du
pouvoir la société serait elle devenue à
ce point atteint de cécité moral car
ignorer ce qu'on a sous les yeux ou
devant les yeux s'est refusé de
percevoir l'autre en l'autre son alter
ego pour en faire l'altérité radicale
justement c'est nier notre commune
humanité celle dont l'autre nous prive à
travers le terrorisme
c'est oublier qu'on ne naît pas
terroriste qu on n'est pas radical mais
qu'on le devient à force de déni de
reconnaissance dans la construction de
nos identités derrière les faits
objectifs ce qu'alain voile où se dresse
un voile un voile d'ignorance cette fois
qui refuse la remise en question de nos
propres modèles sociaux ainsi qu'une
réflexion sur notre responsabilité
collective c'est à dire à tous car oui
mesdames messieurs c'est notre société
qui génère du radicalisme
c'est notre société qui génère des
radicaux c'est notre société qui crée
les conditions de possibilité du réel et
de son double il existe bien bel et bien
un monde invisible pour vous et pour moi
auquel seuls certains ont accès et qui
constitue à fkih consiste à fuir le réel
pour adhérer à ce qui n'est pas à diluer
ce réel que l'on aille pour le rendre
soluble aux hommes politiques étaient
totalement fantasmée
est totalement illusoire à défaut de ne
pas sentir écouté certains font tout
pour être entendus et part craint de ne
pas être entendus ils sont prêts à tout
ils sont capables de tout il ne sert à
rien de détruire les projets des fous de
dieu quel que soit l'avenir l'illusion
perdurera pourquoi parce que les
conditions de possibilité du monde
virtuel vont rester entière est intacte
et si le califat neige disparaît il
restera toujours un califat biens
virtuels celui-là générateur d'une
multitude de double à notre réalité pas
mal d'étudiants dans la salle je pense
vous allez à l'école l'université pour
apprendre des choses de savoir
développer des compétences à 40 ans
j'aimerais vous dire que il n'ya pas
d'école du réel
nous n'échapperons jamais au réel parce
que l'humain est dans l'incapacité d'y
échapper
il est inutile et nous crever les yeux
comme il dit seul reste à espérer une
crise lucidité celle qui nous rendra
conscient de la fragilité de notre
humanité et nous permettra de prendre
conscience ou de prendre notre réalité
pour notre désir et non l inverse
dans ce cadre là et uniquement à cette
condition
nous pourrons envisager ensemble que
nous ne vivons pas dans le meilleur des
mondes et qu'un autre réel est possible
je vous remercie
[Musique]